something's happening i've always wanted
to be a vampire it was just a lot of fun
what's going on vampire academy fans the
cast and i are here to answer some of
your burning questions
[Music]
let's go
i read the books growing up and i'm just
like a crazy vampire fan and then now
i'm playing a vampire called mia i'd
actually been to the movies to see
vampire academy when it first released i
wish i could say i was a fan of the
books prior i read the books during the
casting process i'm up to book three so
no spoilers anyone i was familiar with
vampire academy i read the books as a
kid i was a huge fan i do remember
vampire academy and then i do briefly
remember the film yeah it was it was one
of those things where when the audition
came through and i read the name it was
like
no really
i thought it was going to be hot and
it's not that hot but that's fine
because i'm from london and that's cold
filming in spain has honestly been a
dream it's a completely different
culture it's honestly just as beautiful
as it sounds shooting in spain has
proven to be pretty awesome it's
interesting because in the pandemic i
remember thinking gosh you know i've
always wanted to live in another country
and i wonder if i'll ever get the chance
to and because of this show i've now had
the chance to so i'm pretty grateful for
that i had never traveled in my life i
had never been outside of australia
getting here and going straight to work
was so intense because like the culture
shock it really got me it took a bit of
adjusting but i love it here i think the
culture out here is so nice and friendly
it's hard not to love the people when
you get out here and yeah really enjoyed
it
[Music]
the funnier reaction was with my mother
and my sister who i was with because i
just went into the fetal position on the
ground hysterically crying and they're
just going what's wrong yeah it was kind
of an unreal experience because it's
something that you know as an actor you
want so bad and you work for so hard and
you face rejection so much i did 180
auditions 180 different projects i
auditioned for until i got vampire
academy so it was like a lot of hard
work and rewiring how i thought not
necessarily focusing on the outcome but
focusing on the process i was with my
mom and dad and we literally just i
literally just stopped and started
screaming it was a dream come true
facetime my mum immediately there were
tears and it was just a huge opportunity
and i was extremely proud
i relate to my character
a lot i have a passion for equality
in the world and that is about you know
groups that i belong to and that i don't
belong to i think that everybody should
be treated equally and that's at the
heart of who victor is it's motivated
from a place of family and wanting
everyone in his family to be treated the
same in the society so that i deeply
relate to do i relate to tatiana vogel
in real life her ambition
yes some of her actions
no i believe we have many similarities
and probably more differences which has
been quite interesting to step outside
of myself i've definitely learned a lot
from dimitri in respect to patience yeah
just how to be better this guy is a man
of self-mastery and that's encouraged me
a lot okay and the last question asks
what are we most excited about when
vampire academy drops future streamer of
course see you soon on peacock
[Music]
you